[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 y ya está con nosotros en el estudio
Daniela Blandón Dani ya es viernes
nuestro último programa de directo
América de este año que Dios mío qué
noticias nos ha dado este año no no pues
muchas noches quién se iba a imaginar
que la economía iba a ser tan
protagonista este año a veces Pilar
fundamental a veces la gente cree que la
economía no es tan importante pero es
mucho más importante de lo que nos
imaginamos bueno la vimos todos los días
obviamente viviendo no el si no tenemos
dinero no podemos comprar absolutamente
nada vamos a hablar de los varios bancos
centrales del mundo Any que se preparan
para su última reunión del año también
están cerrando como nosotros Claro que
sí que más que cerrar con broche de oro
este año tan complicado Y es que los
responsables de tomar decisiones de
política monetaria o sea los bancos
centrales del mundo dominan la agenda de
la semana que viene esta vez hay muchos
indicios de que ese ritmo agresivo de su
vida de tasas de interés del que hemos
venido hablando en los últimos meses
podría ralentizarse aunque no
desaparecer del todo recordemos que los
bancos centrales suben sus tasas de
interés para desestimular el consumo y
en la medida en que haya menos demanda
menos consumo los precios tienden a
bajar la inflación tiende a bajar
tomemos como ejemplo la reserva Federal
para controlar esa inflación anual que
casi llega al 10% a comienzos de este
año una vez inició la Guerra en Ucrania
El Banco Central de Estados Unidos
emprendió una seguidilla de subidas de
tasas hace un año el banco les prestaba
a los bancos comerciales a una tasa de
entre el cero y el 0,25% que se mantuvo
relativamente baja durante varios años
hoy después de seis salsas consecutivas
les presta a un interés de entre el
3,75% y el 4% Dani Y qué se espera para
esta última reunión del año pues Raúl el
mercado quedó muy sorprendido cuando en
noviembre se reveló que la inflación
anual ya se había desacelerado hasta el
7,7% Entonces si lo vemos desde
comienzos de año era del 9% un poco más
bajó un poco hasta el 7,7% puede parecer
poco pero en realidad mucho para el
mercado aunque también hay que señalar
Raúl que una economía saludable tiene
una inflación entre el dos y el 3% o el
4% anual y no del Siete para aquella
salud económica digamos
inflación tiene que haber inflación Sí
pero entre el 2 y el cuatro por ciento
está bien no el 10% ni el 7%. ese dato
de octubre reavivo de octubre revivo las
esperanzas de que la Fed no fuera tan
agresiva en las próximas reuniones el
martes se va a dar a conocer un nuevo
dato de inflación El que corresponde a
noviembre y el miércoles termina un
nuevo encuentro de dos días de la Fed lo
que espera el mercado basado en
declaraciones que ya ha dado el mismo
presidente de la reserva Federal un
Powell es que haya un nuevo incremento
Sí pero que no sea tan alto como en
ocasiones anteriores por ejemplo que sea
de 50 puntos básicos y no de 75 puntos
como las últimas veces y eso es una
señal para todo el resto de bancos
centrales del mundo que recordemos
siguen muy de cerca las decisiones de la
Fed Aunque cada uno tiene que tomar las
suyas propias basados en Cómo se esté
moviendo la economía Qué otros bancos se
reúnen de qué reuniones tenemos que
estar pendientes bueno el próximo será
un súper jueves en Europa pues se reúnen
los bancos centrales de la zona Euro de
Inglaterra de Suiza y de Noruega se
espera que todos ellos sigan subiendo
las tasas de interés porque la lucha
contra la inflación no ha terminado de
ninguna manera y el enfoque estará ahora
en cuanto las van a subir y también Dani
la vivienda es uno de estos sectores que
más se ha afectado con esta subida de
las tasas de interés por qué pues mire
que en situación tan particular para
muchos puede parecer este un mal momento
para invertir dinero en la compra de una
propiedad ya que el costo del
endeudamiento se está haciendo cada vez
mayor eso no es un secreto lo hemos
venido diciendo
las tasas hipotecarias están altísimas
en Colombia por ejemplo una taza que
antes era del 8% anual hoy están 13 o
14% anual y eso representa mucho dinero
en Estados Unidos otro ejemplo la tasa
promedio anual para una hipoteca 30 años
está hoy en poco más del 5% llegó hasta
el 7% en su momento y esto es casi el
doble de lo que estaba el año pasado Sin
embargo también está ocurriendo otro
fenómeno Y es que como está más difícil
adquirir vivienda eso ha reprimido la
demanda y los precios están a la baja en
qué consiste todo este fenómeno pues
Mire un análisis al respecto de la
agencia especializada bloomberg señala
como durante los últimos 25 años Canadá
ha estado bajo el control de la hoja
inmobiliario más grande del mundo en una
racha casi ininterrumpida de apreciación
de los precios que no ha tenido paralelo
entre sus pares desarrollados como
Australia Nueva Zelanda y Luxemburgo en
el último cuarto de siglo como lo vemos
en el gráfico los precios sean casi
sexto duplicado del país norteamericano
Australia le sigue Nueva Zelanda
Luxemburgo con apreciaciones de hasta
tres y cuatro veces los precios que eran
hace 25 años sin embargo eso se acabó
los mercados inmobiliarios están
experimentando drásticas caídas de
precios por ejemplo en la pandemia
cuando había tasas históricamente bajas
una gran cantidad de personas sacando
préstamos hipotecarios con tasas
variables que por lo general son más
baratas que las fijas con lo que no
contaban era que aunque esas tasas iban
a duplicarse o a triplicarse o a
cuadruplicarse Y eso lo que hace es que
algunos ya no puedan pagar y tengan que
salir de su vivienda y Qué pasa cuando
mucha gente quiere salir de su vivienda
al mismo tiempo
no me cortaste
no aprendiste nada Raúl
estaba concentrado viendo no sé el video
que tenía usted atrás Bueno entonces qué
pasa cuando hay muchas personas
vendiendo un mismo bien y hay poca
demanda Pues que los precios bajan claro
Así es lo básico por favor sí o sea
economía básica
Dani como siempre Muchísimas gracias por
toda la información más adelante más
economía bueno y seguimos hablando de
tasas a ver si de pronto a ver si ya me
queda la información en la cabeza y
nosotros pasamos a saludar a Luis Méndez
con toda la información deportiva